[Música]
entre la prepa y la universidad yo
estuve dos años sin estudiar porque no
me hace todo ni la unam y el politécnico
o dicho de otra manera porque la verdad
es que no apruebe los exámenes ni uno ni
otro
pero luego vendrían más frustraciones
porque ya cuando está estudiando la
licenciatura
intenté entrar a una maestría me pierden
los tiempos y entonces no me dejaron
entrar el colmex y luego cuando ya está
en el doctorado por estar haciendo
teatro no metí los documentos para la
beca conacyt y entonces tampoco me
dieron la habitación
entonces bueno pues la verdad es que ha
fracasado en todo eso pero
pues en la actualidad miren cómo ha
cambiado todo no tengo coche no tengo
casa y ni siquiera tengo un terrenito
pero lo más importante es que estoy
feliz
estoy feliz y como dice mi papá nada más
me falta el dinero verdad la actitud ya
la tengo
y pues yo iría vivo con mis papás
los cuales pues evidentemente son los
dueños de todo
de mi cama de mis sábanas de mi
lamparita de dormir pero la ropa si la
escojo yo también la pago claro y algo
que sí me pertenece lo único que me
pertenece es mi gata que se llama lola
aunque en realidad según yo los nuevos
amigos de friendly no y todo lo que hay
en redes sociales pues en realidad no me
pertenece porque según éste pues no es
de mi pertenencia sino más bien yo soy
propiedad de la gata porque sois humano
entonces pues si lo pensamos de esa
manera pues no tengo nada
y pues no tengo nada pero estoy
tranquilo estoy tranquilo y soy burro
porque mi mamá si me dice me dice tú
eres un burro el pues yo digo que los
papás siempre tienen la razón verdad
entonces la misma mami me dice oye sabes
que eres un burro y el euro pues sí
porque si yo me pusiera a pensar en
todos los problemas las consecuencias no
haría nada y me quedaría ahí centrado
fue frustrado viendo en xlix no o siendo
crítico de juego de tronos y diciendo es
que la larga noche merecía un capítulo
más no dos capítulos más es más una
temporada completa
tú lo sabes
pero yo creo que cuando sentimos el
llamado del corazón
cuando la cadencia de la pasión es tal
que nos impulsa a caminar
debemos dejarla fluir porque solo eso
nos va a permitir crear nuevos mundos
porque solo eso nos va a permitir ser
libres y poder encender esa chispa que
convierta a nuestros sueños en realidad
yo creo que lo más importante de todo
nos va a permitir trascender dentro de
nosotros mismos
por eso yo estoy en contra de todas esas
personas que dicen que la emoción está
peleada con la razón yo creo que no hay
razón sin corazón y no hay emoción sin
reflexión hasta ritmo
creo que algo importante para poder
transformar la realidad es
y hacer un par de matices creo que hay
que hacer un par de matices porque hoy
todo el mundo hablamos de transformar la
realidad y lamentablemente se hace desde
el éxito si ven que estoy como temblando
no estoy temblando estoy vibrando por su
energía
entonces les decía pero que hay que
hacer un par de matices y algo que a mí
me ha servido es
a lo que se le llama comunicación
asertiva al lenguaje asertivo algo
asertivo que tiene que ver con hay que
llamarle a las cosas por su nombre y
pues yo para mí algo que me ha servido
es decir bueno voy a diferenciar entre
lo que es el éxito y la realización
plena porque para mí eso es bien
importante no el éxito se ha convertido
se ha malentendido primero y luego se ha
convertido en un objeto del capitalismo
al cual pareciera que todos y todas
debemos aspirar
hay un estereotipo de persona exitosa
hace esto hacia que ellos se viste así
se peina hacia acá y tiene una voz
específica para el self y verdad pero
está mal eso está muy mal porque en
realidad lo único que hace es reproducir
es reproducir ese espíritu
esta imagen estereotipo capitalista que
hay que quieren imponer sobre todos
nosotros nos hace daño miren yo creo que
los artistas del éxito no son
inalcanzables porque así no los venden
como inalcanzables en realidad y yo creo
que en realidad son inalcanzables y no
porque no tengamos la capacidad de hacer
o mejorar lo que hacen no no va por ahí
porque nos están vendiendo modelos
modelos que están basados en
circunstancias particulares que tienen
su origen en
entornos personales políticos económicos
y sociales
y si entonces nos están vendiendo este
modelo al final lo intentamos asimilar y
solamente nos va a generar estrés
desesperanza y lo peor de todo
que le va a perder sentido a nuestra
existencia y entonces vamos a caer en el
olvido en nuestro propio olvido
qué es lo peor de todo
por eso yo prefiero el otro concepto la
realización plena porque para mí la
manera en la que lo he construido este
concepto no viene con un modelo de héroe
o de éxito
tiene las características que nos
permiten seguir siendo
y manteniendo nuestras particularidades
nuestra esencia nos deja ser humanos
comunes y corrientes nos permite
construir nuestra propia definición del
triunfo sin que nadie nos imponga nada
y por eso yo prefiero este segundo
concepto la realización plena y no el
éxito
el éxito es algo que viene en
consecuencia yo creo que si buscamos el
éxito desesperadamente solamente nos
vamos a caer nos vamos a dar contra la
pared
yo les quiero proponer una dinámica bien
sencillita
y me gustaría
que miran a su alrededor
a la persona que tienen a la izquierda
bueno la otra izquierda
a la derecha no miren de verdad por
favor ayúdenme tantito para ir hacia
atrás hay que mirar hacia atrás hacia
atrás
los que tienen la parte de atrás no hace
falta que miren para no hacer falta
entonces ahora yo les voy a hacer una
pregunta
acaso una de las personas que ustedes
miraron no es excepcional
lo es no lo sabemos a lo mejor sí bueno
sí la conozco verdad pero si no la
conozco no la sabemos no sabemos si mi
amiga que está al lado no me has
presentado por allá no sabemos si mi
amiga puedes darme las respuestas que
estoy buscando no lo sabemos no sabemos
si el profesor que yo creo que por ahí
hay varios profesores no sabemos si al
mirar a mi profesor él me puede a mí
brindar esas vivencias que yo necesito
para mi salud mental que son bien
importantes
miren todos tenemos aquí algo que
hacemos bien algo tenemos que hacer bien
algo algo lo que sea yo creo que no hay
que mirar hacia afuera no hay que mirar
a las redes sociales porque nos están
vendiendo modelos que como dije están
determinados por un contexto eso
solamente nos va a crear frustración y
no nos va a permitir transformar nuestra
realidad pero si miramos esa persona que
está a mi lado si vemos que está
haciendo bien entonces por ahí viene la
felicidad es el primer paso y yo creo
que eso es bien importante no
necesitamos nosotros de ningún molde
para adaptarnos
yo creo que la clave está en no hacerlo
hay que romper el molde
les quiero contar una última anécdota ya
para no aburrirlos es de un amigo
perdió todo la casa el coche todo
él decía que estaba muy frustrado yo le
dije no te preocupes tú un divorcio no
pasa nada
la cuestión está en que primero se
frustró y dijo oye pues perdí todo tal
yo dije bueno pues si mi labor de amigo
es consolarlo tiempo después lo voy a
ver y quería cómo lo llevas ya no no
tengo nada todavía pero pero fíjate que
estoy mejor primero porque fue para mis
hijos y entonces la verdad que eso es
eso es perfecto yo no lo había asimilado
la relación la separación y todas esas
cosas y lo segundo porque entendí que lo
más importante está en mi no perdí nada
en realidad todo lo tengo si tuve la
capacidad para construir eso una vez
porque este era su segundo divorcio
además pequeño detalle verdad 2003 y
tuve la oportunidad para construir eso
una dos veces pues tengo la oportunidad
para construirlo tres veces
y yo creo que es muy mal lo más
importante si perdemos algo de verdad
que no les duela bueno a lo mejor si es
material es un disco de edición inédita
pues los mejores años puede valer
millones pero sí no
no pasa nada lo más importante lo más
valioso está aquí dentro de cada uno de
nosotros dentro de cada una de nosotras
creo que eso es lo importante yo creo
que si toda esta gente lo pudo hacer
creo que es por algo bien sencillo
rompieron el molde
y dijeron pues lo voy a hacer como yo
entienda no necesito una imagen de éxito
no que le tendría no mira quédate ahí en
dos años tres diputados luego tienes
casa luego tiene ese estilo gobiernas el
universo
y por último yo les quiero contar algo
que la verdad bien chistoso pero que
para mí es lo más importante en la vida
ustedes irán eso no tiene nada que ver
tu historia que nos vas a contar pues
pues a lo mejor no pero a mí es la
historia que siempre que la recuerdo
pues me envalentonó portal estaba
recuerden de si tengo que entrar bien
valiente
cuando por fin después de no saber si
dirigir una obra de teatro o caminar por
la luna decidió en 2007 ya dije bueno ya
mira haciendas de tal vas a hacer polito
lo bien perfecto y me dijo mi mamá hay
que piensa gobernar martes yo le dije
bueno pues ya lo veremos no total que
empecé la carrera me fui ya y un día un
día estando en la biblioteca me dice un
amigo hoy estoy buscando trabajo fíjate
que es bien difícil estar aquí y demás
yo dije ah pues yo también soy pobre yo
también tengo que buscar trabajo verdad
literal literal me di la vuelta y vi un
letrero que decía se solicita asistente
para anticuario yo dije eso es perfecto
para mi perfil artístico cosmonauta
emprendedor
si de verdad no creo en la suerte pero
agarre ya me me fui micron sí perfecto
primero ya saben la estancia yo dije
lámparas carísimas cosas carísimas todo
carísimo dijo con sus tantas entre la
bodega y en la bodega veo dos esculturas
preciosas unos caballos indios de madera
una sola pieza todo
y uno de ellos está enfermito parece que
en el traslado la cola a uno de los
caballos se le había aflojado y me
dijeron que sabes tú de todo esto y dije
pues artista y me dijeron nada perfecto
pues de esto depende si te quedas o te
vas y se van y cerraron la puerta y yo
dije a ver si ellos me dejaron ahí
encerrado con todo esto tan caro deben
de ser conscientes de que este caballo
puede quedar como el guernica de picasso
así no todo es cuadrado yo dije pues que
asuman su responsabilidad y yo asumo mi
responsabilidad y me voy por la puerta
ahí voy veo el serrucho bueno yo
recuerdo que desde niño mi papá me decía
no es que tú tienes que saber todo y
hasta comer piedras lo de las piedras
nunca lo he hecho lo demás y entonces
agarré el serrucho y dije bueno pues
este es el momento porque mira esto ya
sea no hay otra forma no lo pensé mucho
la verdad lo debo reconocer y a garry le
corté la cola a julien muerta
y lo dije híjole creo que tenía que
haber pensado un poco porque claro es
una sola pieza toda la madera en un
árbol y lo que no
yo dije pues pues ya está o sea nada más
hay que componer lo mira unos clavos por
aquí no un poco de plastilina plastilina
por acá para rellenar tal luego agarré
un poco de pintura si se me pasta y dije
bueno con la punta de clavo hago las
estrías de la colita para que se vean
llega mi jefe y me dice
mi hijo hoy quedó precioso tal y demás
yo le dije mire la verdad es que los
corte y mi hijo no te quiero y le dije
no no es cierto no me cortes
yo dije no lograr más explicaciones no
vaya a ser que luego de verdad yo dije
tal y me dice pues ya estoy contratado y
yo dije ya de verdad si mi hijo sigue
sencillas
estuve ahí prácticamente tres años y
gracias a ese trabajo yo pude estudiar
mi universidad en el extranjero pero es
que para mí es una historia que es
impresionante porque no sé qué hubiera
hecho en realidad si no lo hubiera
gestionado de esta manera de esta manera
no digo que ustedes lo hagan así la
verdad es que yo no sé si lo volvería a
hacer si lo volvería a hacer
bueno con esto yo lo que les quiero
decir no es algo nuevo no es algo
novedoso en realidad no yo digo yo no
soy quien para contar las historias yo
creo que cada quien se tiene que
construir sus historias no yo por eso
puedo decirlo en mis amigos a partir de
ellos bueno yo selecciono lo que sí
están impuntuales no eso no es un número
que no me interesa el momento verdad
pero no lo digo yo
lo dice la ciencia hay que romper el
molde miren
yo doy clases de ciencia política y en
las políticas públicas hay un gran
debate en la parte está divide en varias
etapas hay una etapa de la
implementación en la implementación de
las políticas públicas hay un debate
teórico que tiene que ver con el hecho
de si los investigadores pierden más
tiempo definiendo el problema o de
manera directa pasan a atacar las causas
es un gran debate que hay
y es un debate que va a seguir porque
los investigadores les encanta discutir
no si esto aquello la cuestión está en
que hay un acuerdo existe ese debate y
este debate lo que nos está diciendo es
que
si nosotros atendemos a la definición
entonces vamos a tener las respuestas
determinadas eso no nos va a permitir a
nosotros optar por otras medidas nos va
a encasillar
si nosotros agarramos un modelo que
además por el contexto no nos
corresponde no vamos a hacer nada
solamente vamos a tener frustraciones
desesperación estrés etc de ser
psicólogos
no lo que yo les quiero decir es que si
nosotros queremos trascender si nosotros
queremos hacer las cosas de manera
diferente si nosotros queremos
transformar la realidad nuestra realidad
hay que hacer las cosas de manera
diferente nosotros tenemos que romper el
molde gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]